GUEST SPEAKER: I'm
going to present to you
some important criteria
by which to evaluate
the legislative proposals
in the legislative hearings.
And I'm going to present
them in my suggested order
of importance of the criteria.
So number one, I would suggest
the most important criterion
is science.
So ask yourself,
does the question
used to evaluate
the proposals, ask
yourself does the proposal
accord with valid research
on maintaining fish populations?
Number two, I would suggest the
second most important criterion
is policy design and economics.
Ask yourself does the proposal
include a well-designed policy?
And number three,
I would suggest
that the third most important
criterion is politics.
Ask yourself does the
proposal have support and is
it likely to pass, or can
you make it likely to pass?
Values and management
are two other criteria
that I have not ranked in
the top three for this issue.
If you take a look at
the handout on the board,
you'll see why I haven't
ranked management
as the most important
criterion for this issue.
We already have the
Magnuson-Stevens Act,
which is the federal legislation
used to manage fisheries.
And since it was revised in 1996
you can see the top map shows--
with the red circles,
all the red circles
are fish populations
that have recovered
in the New England states, your
home constituency since 2000.
And the graph on the bottom
shows an overall decline
in fish stocks that are
having measured as overfished.
So this isn't primarily a
management problem because we--
there will doubtless be
proposals with management
problems, but for this
issue, we at least
know that management
is possible and we
know that we have some
success in managing this issue
federally.
So we have some
organizational capacity
that we're already aware of.
So now I'm going to go
over the three top criteria
and why I've ranked
them that way
with some important questions
to use to gather information
during the hearings for
each of the criteria.
So number one is science.
Science I've ranked as the
most important criterion
for this issue because
science is our best
tool for understanding
the natural world, which
includes fisheries.
Also, it's very
important for this issue
because as you may
know, there seems
to be legitimate disagreement
about the science
on this issue.
So it's very important for you
to use the hearings to assess--
you're going to
have to take a stand
on which of the science
that's presented to you
you think is valid.
And that's going
to underpin how do
you assess the other criteria.
You're going to have to
take a stand on science
in order to decide which
legislation to support.
You can't really assess the
policy design for example,
without knowing what science
you think is legitimate.
Some really important
questions to ask yourself
about the science
during the hearings,
some important
information to gather,
it's important to
find out who funded
the research, each research
that's presented to you.
Also whether the
research was published
in a peer-reviewed journal.
Peer-reviewed research has
been vetted by other scientists
and has had criticism
from other scientists who
weren't involved in it.
Non-peer reviewed research
there's no guarantee of that.
Ask yourself, is
there broad agreement
among other scientists
with this research
or is this research presented
by one or two scientists
and the rest of the scientific
community disagrees with them?
And in general,
just ask yourself
when a proposal presents
a method of management,
what ways of management,
of fisheries management,
have data to show that
they're actually effective.
So going on to number two,
policy design and economics.
That's also a very
important criterion
because any policies
effectiveness
is going to be dependent
on it being well-designed.
And the economic
costs of each proposal
are real both to
your constituents
and to the federal government.
And so far, we have
very little information
about the different
proposals policy designs.
So it is important
to gather information
during the hearings
about the policy design.
So some important
questions to ask yourself
are what are the economic costs
associated with each proposal
both to your constituents,
both short-term cost
and long-term costs
both to our state
and to the federal government?
What are the economic benefits
of each proposal again,
both short-term and long-term?
It's important to ask yourself
of the proposals which
proposal is the least coercive
while still being effective?
So if we can incorporate some
aspects of self-organization
of the fisheries
industry that will often
make it a less coercive policy.
Also from the policy
design standpoint,
an important question to try to
suss out from the hearings is,
are the fisheries likely
to comply with the policy?
Who's going to make them
comply if they don't?
Who will implement the policy?
LAWRENCE SUSSKIND: 20 seconds.
GUEST SPEAKER: And
moving on to politics,
politics is important because
your re-election is important
and because the hearings
are an important time
to gather political information.
LAWRENCE SUSSKIND:
Thank you, very much.
Good.
Good job.